this is all well and good on flat ground
but what's about when you get to a hill
finally a way to bike without getting a
sore butt we went by a perfectly normal
transport to the Netherlands to meet
Rouen its inventor mechanical engineer
an incredible optimist I unwrapped it in
this very living room and I was sitting
down and just enjoyed it for a few
moments almost almost getting emotional
with it and I thought this is going to
be the product this is going to be a
success how does the lobby fit work to
get it started the user has to push back
a little bit with their foot that kicks
the bike into motion from there on out
the treadmills moving the bicycles going
and the human operator sets the speed on
the handlebars but how does the electric
motor drive the back wheel while keeping
you fit on the treadmill drum has used
an arrangement of three sprockets
connected by a drive chain this means
that the treadmill can go
counterclockwise whilst the rear wheel
can go clockwise thanks to some elegant
engineering you can have a relaxing
stroll while the electric motor is
taking you to work the coolest thing is
that normal walking is a slow sluggish 3
miles per hour or 5 kilometers per hour
get on the lobby fit and you got a
maximum of 15 miles per hour or 25
kilometers per hour but if you want to
get some exercise as you move along it
might just be easier to ride a bike
you